>>> WENDY IS GOING GRAY.
IN CANADA THE FAST FOOD GIANT
CHANGED THE HAIR COLOR IN THE
RED-HEADED LOGO IN SUPPORT OF A
NEWS ANCHOR WHO SAYS SHE LOST
HER JOB AFTER GOING GRAY DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
>> I WAS BLINDSIDED, AND I'M
STILL SHOCKED AND SADDENED BY
BELL MEDIA'S DECISION.
AT 58 I STILL THOUGHT I'D HAVE A
LOT MORE TIME TO TELL MORE OF
THE STORIES THAT IMPACT OUR
DAILY LIVES.
>> PARENT COMPANY BELL MEDIA
SAYS THE NARRATIVE THAT LISA'S
AGE, GENDER OR GRAY HAIR PLAYED
IN THE DECISION IS NOT THE CASE,
DESPITE REPORTS THAT AN
EXECUTIVE ASKED WHO APPROVED THE
DECISION TO, QUOTE, LET LISA'S
HAIR GO GRAY.
WITH ME CNN CHIEF BUSINESS
CORRESPONDENT CHRISTINE ROMANS
AND CNN NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
ERICA HILL.
SO I KIND OF FEEL LIKE I WANT TO
STEP BACK AND NOT BE PART --
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THERE IS A
DOUBLE STANDARD IN THIS BUSINESS
WE HAVE CHOSEN.
ANYONE WHO SAYS THERE ISN'T
HASN'T BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
HERE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> EVERYTHING YOU KNOW, HOW YOU
PERFORM, HOW YOU INTERVIEW, HOW
YOU ARE IN THE FIELD AND HOW YOU
LOOK.
IN THIS CASE THIS IS SOMEONE
WITH A 35-YEAR TRACK RECORD, WHO
WON A MAJOR CANADIAN
BROADCASTING AWARD IN APRIL, WHO
COVERED THE PAPAL APOLOGY FOR
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE CHILDREN IN
THAT COUNTRY, COVERED IRAQ,
AFGHANISTAN, OLYMPICS, IT GOES
ON AND ON.
YET, A BUSINESS DECISION, NOT
PERFORMANCE, A BUSINESS DECISION
IS WHY SHE WAS TOLD SHE WOULD BE
LEAVING HER CAREER AFTER 35
YEARS.
A BUSINESS DECISION THAT
APPARENTLY LOOKS LIKE THE WAY
SHE APPEARS.
>> THE WAY SHE APPEARS AND/OR
HER AGE.
THE COMBINATION OF THE TWO.
YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
IN THIS BUSINESS, AND WE KNOW
IT, A MAN WITH GRAY HAIR, WHITE
HAIR, EVEN A LITTLE BELLY IS
SEEN WITH HAVING GRAVITAS AND
BEING DISTINGUISHED.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
WE SIGNED UP FOR THIS.
I WOULD HOPE I GET TO 58.
YES, I DO COLOR MY HAIR.
SOME DAY MAYBE I'LL GO GRAY AND
IF I'M LUCKY, I'LL LOOK AS
FABULOUS AS LISA.
>> SHE LOOKS FABULOUS.
>> I'M NOT THERE YET BUT I
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE.
IT SHOULDN'T MATTER WHAT YOUR
HAIR COLOR IS.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED, TOO, IF
PART OF THIS IS MONEY.
OH, YOU MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY.
AND YET, I BET SHE MAKES LESS
THAN HER MALE COUNTERPARTS.
>> THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH PUBLIC
SUPPORT FOR THIS ANCHOR, FROM
DOVE, "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED,"
WENDY'S, AS WE POINTED OUT.
I THINK MANAGERS CLEARLY NEED TO
READ THE ROOM AND GET WITH THE
TIMES THAT PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
SEEING COOKIE CUTTER IMAGES OF
WHAT WOMEN ARE SUPPOSED TO LOOK
LIKE, AND BEYOND JUST
APPEARANCES, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT NO NOTE THAT DIVERSITY
BENEFITS EVERYONE, NOT JUST
DIVERSITY IN THE TRADITIONAL
SENSE, ALTHOUGH, OF COURSE, THAT
HELPS, BUT DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT,
HAVING DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES,
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT LEADS TO
MORE INNOVATIVE WORKPLACES,
LEADS TO MORE AGILE COMPANIES
THAT ARE BETTER PREPARED TO DEAL
WITH THE PROBLEMS OF TODAY.
I THINK WE MISS THAT WHEN WE
SORT OF MINIMIZE PEOPLE IN TERMS
OF HOW GOOD THEY LOOK.
ALTHOUGH, TO REPEAT THE OBVIOUS,
SHE LOOKS FANTS.
>> IT HAD MAY MUSK ON THE COVER
RECENTLY, ELON'S MOM AND SHE
LOOKS FANTASTIC.
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" COVER WITH
A GRAY WOMAN ON THE COVER.
IT'S NOT JUST THE YOUNG, SKINNY,
BLONDE 25-YEAR-OLD WHICH IS WHAT
WOMEN RELATE TO.
WOMEN RELATE TO A LOT OF
DIFFERENT BODY TYPES.
>> AND WOMEN HAVE MORE BUYING
POWER.
THERE WAS A TIME NOT TOO LONG
AGO WHEN A WOMAN COULDN'T HAVE A
CHECKING ACCOUNT OR CREDIT CARD
WITHOUT HER HUSBAND SIGNING OFF.
THIS COVETED DEMOGRAPHIC OF 25
TO 54 FOR TV ADVISERS, THEY WANT
TO SEE, TO YOUR POINT, WE'LL USE
OUR DOLLARS THAT WAY.
>> 40 IS THE KNEW 50.
SERENA WILLIAMS LAST NIGHT, 41
YEARS OLD.
IT'S ALL CHANGING.
>> WASN'T A SUPP VISOR, WASN'T
SOMEONE I WORKED FOR.
A FEW YEARS AGO BEFORE I STARTED
GOING GRAY, NATURALLY IT'S
HAPPENING, QUITE RAPIDLY.
IT WAS SUGGESTED TO ME I SHOULD
DYE MY HAIR GRAY SO I HAD MORE
GRAVITAS.
WHAT YOU SAID THERE, THERE WAS
IS SENSE FOR ME AS A DUDE --
>> YOU LOOK TOO YOUNG.
>> YOU'RE STILL LIKE THE YOUNG
25-YEAR-OLD BOY ON THE BUS.
>> EXACTLY.
IT SHOWS THERE'S A DOUBLE
STANDARD IN THIS BUSINESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED IN
CANADA.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO KNOW THE
INSIDE WORKINGS OF THAT STORY.
>> AND PROBABLY NEVER WILL.
>> I WILL SAY IT WAS A HUGE
SCREW-UP BY WHOEVER MADE THAT
DECISION.
THE NEGATIVE BLOWBACK AND HOW
PETTY AND SHORTSIGHTED THEY LOOK
WHEN YOU HAVE ALL THESE VIEWERS
THAT HAVE COME TO HER DEFENSE
AND COMPANIES BASICALLY POKI